at the department will keep an eye on
everything that's going on the hospital
Wards in Stockton this is what the PM
wants to be seen to be focusing on
anything it's your model that we need to
do a bit more of but the PM is presiding
over anything but model governance to
Cabinet ministers gone within his first
hundred days another still under
investigation informs you who's
responsible for the next step
a PM Keen to get onto the next steps
today we have a new plan for NHS
emergency care more beds more ambulances
more staff better social care and if we
can deliver big promises but the NHS in
bad shape with even bigger problems
Workforce retention wages waiting times
none of it good average ambulance wait
times for heart attacks and Strikes in
December you'll know when 90 minutes the
NHS standard is 18 minutes to give
people the best chance to survive but
today you're not even recommitting to
get back to that Target at all my point
to you is people watching this will
think that that is not good enough and
do you accept it's going to take years
to fix the NHS of course it's not good
enough of course gosh what happened in
December was not was not great no right
it was not great for any of you working
in the NHS it was not great for patients
tough times for patients and staff and
tough times too for the PM as he fronts
up to the uncomfortable cabinet scandal
today making his first public remarks
after sacking his party chair I was able
to make a very quick decision that it
was no longer appropriate for nadines
are we to continue in government and
that's why he's no longer there and
that's what I've done
for new mums here in Darlington the NHS
and the care it offers essential for
their newborns but they also care about
cabinet ministers paying their taxes
properly
yeah a good start probably
[Music]
um
there's always a imbalance between how
the little man gets treated when they
make those kind of mistakes and how the
elite are treated if you can't trust
them then why would you elect them yeah
why would you continue to to vote for
them so yeah for me the trust scores
trust matters and whatever the Prime
Minister says about cleaning up politics
it's clear from talking to people here
in Darlington that the Scandal over
Nadeem sahawi's tax Affairs really does
stick and it leaves the Prime Minister a
hundred days into his Premiership still
struggling to make any real impression
over policy or principles with voters
[Applause]
if the NHS will help stop
number 10 hard to raise what's gone
before it's hard to have a fresh start
after 13 years in power Beth Rigby Sky
News in Darlington